[Music]
in the end I just have to make sure that
I follow my heart and do whatever I feel
is best and did she ever nine Studio
albums five Grammy Awards Christine has
become one of the most celebrated
singers of our time but 20 years ago we
were introduced to the real xtina with
the release of her album strict
[Music]
I think that I took the reins of of
needing to be in control of my career
and my destiny as a woman when I
released the album strip yes she was
open about her sexuality and drive to
empower women
[Music]
but she also became a fierce Ally to the
queer Community with the Glad media
Awards praising Christina for the anthem
beautiful the video features a gay
couple and a transgender woman a
progressive move for 2002. you are
beautiful
and that allyship continued on June 12
2016 49 people were killed in a mass
shooting at lgbtq plus nightclub pulse
in Orlando Christina donated proceeds of
her single change to benefit the
victim's families posting on her website
we all have the choice to spread love
encourage individuality and make a
difference to others we are all in this
together as one United in love
xtina continued to spread the love by
appearing on the mega hit series
RuPaul's Drag Race and in true Queen
Fashion she headlined an epic concert
for La pride in the park this summer
speaking to people about her continued
support of the lgbtq plus Community I
think that you can only be an ally to
things that you believe in and that
you're passionate about I mean the whole
Community has just been they're my
friends they've been a support system
and people that truly fight for their
own freedom and their own voice to be
heard that's what I've always you know
had behind my messages of my music since
since I was able to make stripped